uh welcome back everyone I just finished
my round two game and the creguero chess
tournaments and it's currently 11 32 p.m
um I just had a really long crazy game
so I don't know how much longer I'm
gonna be awake but at least I'll try and
highlight the key moments of this game
uh I was on board three playing one of
the top seeds Valentin dragneov uh
strong ground master from Austria I
think his feeder rating is around 25.50
and there wasn't much time to prepare it
before the game I did check his openings
and I saw he just plays everything so I
really went into this game without much
preparation and we ended up going into a
sicilian rosalimo variation and this is
an opening that I've been studying
actually recently from the black side
and I play the move here which I've
never played over the board because Pawn
to G6 in the past I played Pawn E6 like
my go-to move sometimes I play E6 on
move 2 and Sicilian but Pawn G6
um kind of inspired by uh by Magnus
actually
um Magnus Carlsen uh has played this
line uh with good success over recent
years including in the world
championship match against Fabiano and
um yeah I figured I'd just go into
something new that I haven't played
before because that's one of the best
ways to learn in chess but it's also
kind of risky in a serious tournament uh
kind of going outside my comfort zone
and um we got one of the main lines
after trade on C6 D3 Bishop G7 H3 this
is all pretty standard and then my
opponent here played a move that I have
not studied uh Pawn A4 and this is very
much a sideline let me just see A4 is
the fourth most popular move I was
familiar with other kind of main lines
here
um actually one trap uh just uh to show
a cool opening trap if white plays a
natural looking Bishop E3 which is the
third most common move on each us
there's actually a nice tactic Knight
takes E4 and this is I believe just
better for black because 2 is hit
so just small tidbits of opening prep as
white you still need to be careful on
this line but A4 uh is perhaps a more
modern approach uh and maybe inspired by
like Leela or Alpha zero just trying to
go for this positional bind on the queen
side and I tried to continue normally I
played Knight D7 which is one of the
main ideas to support E5 and then
eventually maneuver the Knight to E6 uh
A5 was played castling castling play E5
Knight D2 Queen E7 a lot of normal moves
here actually if I toggle Masters
database uh we are still following a
game between ivanchuk and laco so in uh
in somewhat decent company uh and here
my opponent plays a novelty Pawn C3 but
very logical
um just kind of solidifying the center
and
um yeah we're gonna see in a few moves
one of the points behind C3 so here I
went for Knight f8 uh trying to maneuver
the night to E6 and also unleash my Rook
Queen C2 was played and now the issue
here for black is I can't immediately
play 96 because that would hang the pawn
on E5
um so I was trying to figure out like a
useful move to play and in hindsight
maybe I should have played Queen C7 to
support 96 uh but during the game I
thought that it would be nice to get in
B5 and kick away the knight from C4 and
I can't play B5 immediately because
there is on passant and then there's a
pin on a file
so I decided here to play Rook to B8 uh
supporting the b-pawn and after Bishop
E3 I went ahead and played B5 but very
soon we're going to see the drawback of
this move after Pawn Dick's Pawn Pawn
takes Pawn
um here my opponent play the move which
I really just overlooked during the game
and I I overlooked how strong this move
is uh now I'm hiding notation because I
don't want to spoil things too much uh
but the move of my opponent played was
Pawn to B4
and this turned out to be really strong
and I guess it was one of the points of
playing C3 earlier supporting this
b-pawn bush and now my pawns are are
actually very delicate here
um because the natural looking
C takes B4 is met with Bishop takes B6
hitting the rook and then white can
regain the pawn next with uh with a very
nice position
and if I don't resolve the tension here
uh White's ready to take and just
destroy my Pawn structure so I was in a
little bit of a pickle and I played a
move which I really didn't want to play
and I spent a lot of time here uh to
play Knights to D7 we can see the time
stamps I had just over under just under
an hour and I took about uh what 12 or
13 minutes to play this move
I was really sad because I really wanted
to get the Knight to E6 but I returned
to D7 blocking my rook and Bishop and
it's just purely a passive square but I
figured this was one of the best tries
to hold on and it gets even sadder
because my opponent plays Rook A7 and
just here it seems like I'm completely
tied down and
um
yeah I was struggling to find a move
here I'm even forgetting what I played
oh no where's my team I'm out of tea oh
life is so sad on and off the board
but it gets happier just wait
um so I played Rook to B7 uh just trying
to neutralize the seventh rank
um and try and trade off a pair of hooks
my opponent says no thank you plays Rook
A8 and I was still sad
um but then I found a somewhat active
move I played Pawn to B5
chasing away the knights now I was
reluctant to play this move because
after 95 Rook C7 it's still really
really passive Now The Rook is tied down
to the Sea pawn and I thought white had
a pretty strong option here which um my
point didn't play in the game he played
Rook to C1
I was thinking during the game that he
complained like B3 and essentially leave
the B4 Pawn hanging and if I take it
takes takes takes there's a really nice
tactic for white Bishop D2 with
um an eventual skewer coming on A5 so
Queen moves Bishop A5 and White's
winning material
so I thought my opponent would
get to at least this position and I
think I was planning to take once and
play Bishop B7 and continue to be sad
but um that didn't happen Rook C1 was
played and then I realized I have a
chance to try and just make the game
messy and there's a move here which I
think once I considered I was kind of
excited about and I went ahead and
played a very energetic move Pawn to F5
um now it seems a little bit risky to
expand on the king side and weaken my
king while I'm really tied down on the
queen side but I thought there's a lot
of usefulness to this move because I
really want to play F4 and get rid of
the bishop on E3 either make it move
back or trade off on C5 and um I thought
maybe this move could lead to some
eventual attack on the king side as well
but uh yeah from here things get crazy
after takes takes
plays Rook T1 which I think was very
logical
um understanding that The Rook is better
placed on the half open E file for white
and here I played Bishop to F6 I was
pretty pleased with this move
um preventing any Bishop G5 Shenanigans
also preparing Queen G7 where the queen
can still support the pawn at the same
time try and generate some attack
against white king
so white takes and um here I played my
next move and then right after I played
the move I realized I had slightly
miscalculated we'll explain what I was
thinking here I was thinking I'll take
the pawn
uh White plays D4 which looks very
logical and then I have E4
on E3 but Pawn E4 counter attack
midnight
and at first I thought this line is like
all good for black because it takes
takes and
um it would be a fair trade but uh Pawn
on F3 is actually really nice and
there's not much like can do with the
discovered attack on the e-file
uh let me just play this on the board
because this is a position that we got
um and I had overlooked White's next
move in this position which my opponent
played Bishop to F4 which is really
really strong
um hitting the rook and unleashing the
pin along e-file and my knight is still
hanging
so at this point it looks like
everything is going wrong for black I
have no time to take the knights my Pawn
is pinned and there's multiple things
hanging in my position and the move I
really wanted to play here
um
especially
especially like beforehand like before
we got to this position I was
calculating this line I was calculating
Knight to D3 which looks like it almost
saves black but then white has a really
nice way to simplify Queen takes D3
takes takes and then if I take with
Bishop I lose the rook and if I take
with the Rook I get Fort and in the very
end of things I'm going to be down upon
I was trying to make this work but after
takes takes this Pawn is more weak than
it is strong
so I didn't play Knight D3 and uh I was
getting really low on time here
um I think I spent the most of my
remaining time
um I eventually settled on Knight E6 uh
yeah we can see I spent about five
minutes so falling below four minutes
but I played 96 because it at the very
least it keeps the game going even
though it loses material uh it's a move
to try and cut my losses I break the pin
on the e-file and after it takes I take
back with queen and I do lose exchange
but at the same time I'm hitting the
Knight and maybe there's chances of
counter play and here my opponent kind
of surprised me he played the move
Knight D2 I was expecting 95 which is a
bit more active and if takes takes I
can't take the pawn because my C Pawn
would hang and I would get Fort so
I thought 95 was a better option
um I forget exactly what I was planning
to play here
um
yeah my mind is kind of just mesh mesh
mashed potatoes at this point but uh
it's been a long day so Knight D2 was
played and then I began feeling some
change of momentum because I played
Knight F4 and all of a sudden White's
pieces look a little bit ridiculous The
Rook on a 9985 aren't really doing that
much and there's already ideas of Queen
G7 with a pretty vicious attack against
the king not to mention Knight D3 ideas
and this Knight would be
um just as valuable as a rook if it gets
to the D3 Square so my opponent played
King H1 and here I played King h8 uh
preparing Rook G8 I really want to use
the G file uh Knight F1 was played and
now Rook G8 hitting the pawn Knight to
E3 defending the pawn
um but then I played Knight to D3 so I'm
just keeping initiative trying to make a
threat with every move and this move has
essentially two threats I'm attacking
The Rook but I'm also making way for my
Pawn to come to F4 and it's incredible
how how the tides turned because about
five moves earlier I was feeling like I
was gonna lose pretty quickly and now it
feels like I'm on the verge of winning
my opponent plays Rook to G1 and I play
F4 and I left one and then Bishop E6 at
this point I I was feeling really good
even though I'm below a minute opponent
still has about five minutes uh Bishop
E6 is a way to simplify a bit very
forcing
um opponent takes and when he took the
Rook he actually offered me a draw which
was generally good sign when um much
higher rated player offers you a draw I
immediately uh took back and just
declined so I figured that it's only a
black playing for a win here
and then he plays F3 now I should
mention
um I'm hitting the Knight and if Knight
moves back then there's a nice sign
Bishop takes B3 Queen B3 Knight F2 King
H2 and then I think I was gonna play F3
this looks really really nice for black
um discovered attack and these pawns are
monstrous so F3 was a clever way of
trying to muddy the waters uh leaving
the knights hanging but if I take it
then takes and it's not so clear I have
two minor pieces for The Rook but white
has a nice Center and like Knight is a
little bit stuck on D3
so instead of taking the Knight I opted
for Bishop to D5 uh just reinforcing the
pawn and this bishop is so so happy now
um Knight B3 was played and then I'm
still like very low on time I was trying
to just calculate the forcing lines
trying to find
um uh a winning sequence because I I
have a lot of forcing moves here between
Bishop takes B3 and Knight E1 and pawn
takes F3 uh it just seems like such a
fun position to calculate but yeah
unfortunately I spent all my time
earlier in the game so I I had to make a
split second decision I think I let my
clock tick down to to two seconds and
then I played the move
Pawn takes F3 yeah
um there was a 30 second increment so I
did fall to two seconds there now
interestingly enough there is a
straightforward win here for black I
only found this out after the game
um it's somewhat of an engine move it's
not even the move I considered in this
position but if you want to try and find
the move uh feel free to pause the video
but I'll go ahead and show the cleanest
win for black is Bishop H4
and I should have at least had this move
on my radar because it does thread a
mating sequence if white takes or if I
just doesn't address a threat I'm ready
to play Knight F2 King H2 Bishop G3
takes and then takes and this is just an
absolutely beautiful checkmates uh Pawn
Knights work amazingly together and this
would have been a Rosen trophy as well
check meeting with a pawn
um unfortunately that didn't happen
and I took the pawn on F3 with idea that
after Queen digs D3
I'm trapping the rook and I'm winning
back the exchange uh the problem with
this line is we're simplifying and even
though I went back material it's going
to lead to a position that is equal
material
um so Knight D2 was played I play Queen
G7 I figured The Rook is trapped there's
no reason to take it immediately I was
trying to stir up play it against G7
um or against G2 for that matter
um and I am threatening made in two here
with takes and takes
so my opponent played Knight to F3 and
in this position I played a move which I
thought was really really strong in the
moment it turns out the move I played
was another another missed opportunity
uh it turns out in this position I have
another
just amazing way to win and it's a
really really nice tackle sequence that
again I found out after the game with
the help of stockfish so I'll go ahead
and share the move that I played is Pawn
to B4 but if again if you want to try
and find the winning move for black feel
free to pause the video but the move is
Bishop takes F3 and of course a pawn
digs back it's mating so when the queen
takes the key idea is to sacrifice the
bishop on D4 and this was would have
been absolutely beautiful it just didn't
come to mind uh during the game
especially given my time situation uh
the point here is after takes takes
The Rook is trapped and the Queen and
pawn form a battery so there's a maiden
one threat and there's really no Escape
for white maybe there's an attempt
Knight E3
but then there's a funny line Queen E3
take take and the pawns are just too
strong like Rook C1 E2 and black is
winning so that would have been really
nice but uh yeah I played B4 instead
and I had the same idea I was trying to
undermine the structure so that after
takes I wanted to take take and get the
same idea but with the bishop on D4
the problem is white is able to hold
things together with a move Knight one
to D2 and now I just don't have the same
tactics The Rook is ready to escape so I
had to take and after King takes
um I had the decision here whether to
take or play B3 and during the game I
really wanted to play B3 but I wasn't
sure what's happening after C4 so I
decided to take
after Queen takes we got to a position
where it's two Bishops against two
knights and both sides have Queen in
three Pawns so I thought it was still
playing for a winier given that there's
a lot of pressure on white
um but it turns out white is really
solid and we did a little bit of dancing
around
um King H2 I was threatening Queen E3
which uh would have liquidated into a
nice ending for Black like King H2 was
very accurate I go back Queen B4 check
King G1 I go back
and actually in this position there was
a funny moment because I played Queen G8
with five seconds left and right after I
played it I thought I blundered queen D6
and it looks like white is winning at
four Pawn here causes black defend
um because if Bishop G5 there's Queen E5
but uh it turns out that uh there's a
nice tactic Bishop takes D4 and then I
just pinned it to G2 so
if this happened hopefully I would have
found Bishop D4 I'm pretty sure my point
saw that and um for that reason played
King H2 essentially offering
um repetition but I was still trying to
play for a win queen d8 king G1 Bishop
B7
um more dancing around got my queen D6
Bishop on D6
and then yeah I tried to improve
offered a queen trade and white declined
put the queen on E7
and then here I saw a forcing move
Bishop to B4
and after Queen B6 I was really trying
to make the tactics work like it's still
tactical despite the fact it's an end
game I went for the lion takes takes and
then Bishop takes G2
um the problem is it's just liquidates
completely into a draw and I'm pretty
sure I didn't really have anything
better like if I play Queen E2 or the
main threat then I'm subjecting myself
to checks and my king really doesn't
have much shelter here
so Bishop G2 was just a safe option
after it takes check I win the night and
I am temporarily up a pawn and if white
takes here I would take with check but
my opponent uh very correctly gives a
check on C7 and now if I move my king to
the sixth rank light would take the Palm
with check so we ended up repeating here
and a game ended peacefully
I played King f8 and offer the draw my
opponent accepted
and that was my round two game still
processing what happened
um there were a couple missed wins on my
part uh it's very difficult like
especially when the momentum shifts
during the game and I went from having
just a very bad looking position to
being on the verge of winning
um and then on top of that with time
trouble it was just very hard
psychologically to find like the
accurate moves to close things out
um would have been nice to find these
killer tactics
um especially this bishop H4 move or
later this um the sacrifice on D4 but
overall I think this is a very
interesting instructive hopefully
entertaining game and
um and yeah two more games tomorrow I
think it's time to sleep uh I think I
passed a 20 minute Mark but it's still
before midnight so hopefully I can get
at least eight hour hours of sleep but
um yeah that does it thanks for watching
and stay tuned for more Recaps see you
soon